il danse depuis l'âge de 3 ans il est le
danseur étoile du ballet national du
canada depuis 2004 et son chorégraphe
depuis 2013 il a interprété les plus
grandes oeuvres du ballet classique
s'est produit sur les plus grandes
scènes du monde et il est considéré
comme l'un des plus grands danseurs de
sa génération
la danse et la vie de guillaume côté
d'adam sont toujours faire partie de ma
vie
c'est ce que j'ai toujours dans ces
mêmes camps jouent être quand je ma
carrière est terminée
une carrière qui commence alors qu'il
n'a que 11 ans le petit guillaume quitte
sa famille son lac saint-jean natale
pour aller étudier à l'école nationale
de ballet du canada à toronto
deux mois plus tard il parle anglais
couramment s'est faits plein d'amis et
nagent dans le milieu comme un poisson
dans l'eau
c'est en 1999 qu'il intègre le ballet
national du canada et depuis sa carrière
s'est envolé vers les plus hauts sommets
de la danse ici comme ailleurs je salage
de crâne de 33 ans c'est là que j'ai
vraiment acquérez la bonne maturité puis
ma fiscalité va probablement être bonne
encore jusqu'à 40 ans fait que cgt comme
ça si cette hausse cache vraiment non
seulement
en parallèle à sa [ __ ] danseurs
guillaume côté mène une carrière de
chorégraphe
il a déjà produit plusieurs spectacles
couronnés de succès comme une adaptation
du petit prince est depuis des mois il
travaille aux côtés de robert lepage
pour un spectacle frame by frame dont la
première se tiendra le 1er juin à
toronto
un beau défi pour le danseur qui rêvait
depuis des années de collaborer avec le
célèbre metteur en scène
avoir quelqu'un comme robert qui rendant
dans l'équation je trouve que ça ça
brasse la cage ça fait que ont tout d'un
coup on réalise que ok il y avait
vraiment des choses à faire pour
accentuer la danse encore plus ses potes
d'enlever la danse pilote de remplacer
par du multimédia c'est pas ça du tout
ou remplacer sa part départ des tricks
de cendre mais c'est vraiment de jumeler
les deux pour que la danse soit vue
d'une façon différente
un différend 29 ont été différents
angles de voir la danse que de
travailler le matériel de la danse
classés
faire avancer son art se renouveler
sortir des sentiers battus et de sa zone
de confort vivre de nouvelles
expériences
guillaume côté aime l'audace ce que je
sais beaucoup dans ma main dans ma vie
en général c'est c'est ça c'est m'ouvrir
pas mal plus sur le monde parce que je
trouve que l'on vive
on vit dans un monde tellement petit
maintenant il ya traitement moyen avoir
accès tellement d'histoire de culture a
deux façons de faire à deux styles
différents de danse de musique qu'on me
forcer à faire des choses différentes
jamais répéter les mêmes choses dans le
sens que j'aimerais découvrir de
nouvelles choses que je connais pas
encore
c'est dans cette perspective qu'il a
accepté en 2014 de devenir le directeur
artistique du festival des arts de
saint-sauveur dans les laurentides
[Musique]
l'occasion aussi pour ce père de deux
jeunes enfants qui a épousé une danseuse
de reprendre contact avec le québec où
il s'est peu produits et où il espère
revenir vivre un jour ce québec qu'il a
quitté six jeunes n'est qu'il aime
passionnément
d'ici là il va continuer à défendre son
art avec conviction la danse c'est la
plus belle investissements qu'on peut
faire parce que c'est un investissement
de temps c'est un investissement de
corps et d'âme je pense que je veut
répandre le message que la balance et
c'est important tout le monde qui sait
c'est pas la danse classique cependant
lorsqu'on apprend ça peu de la danse en
toutes les formes
l'étoile n'est pas juste sur la scène
elle continue de briller quand les
projecteurs s'éteignent
[Musique]